so I wasn't thinking of asking you this
but as we've come from that this is this
comes from man this this moral code
comes from your mind so then we're in
this system something like abortion now
you're protecting the individual this is
all been about the individual so what is
in the womb that child is an individual
and yet you want the government out so
how do you have no regulation when it
comes to abortion because you want to
protect the individual and yet you want
no regulator there's some level of fight
here I know a lot of crap from my point
of view on abortion oh well I'm glad
there's gonna be a lot of people that
hate me for this and I've had some
Twitter wars with people over it look to
me rights are a social moral concept
like I said before if you're on a desert
island you know there's you don't you
don't have to worry about the concept of
right because the only person who can
stop you from acting or thinking is
another person right so you do what you
gotta do right and those so that that's
where rights are applicable so to me the
concept of abortion the woman's as a is
already existing value already pursuing
life her choice is pretty much all that
matters and until the child is born when
it's now in a social environment when
when it's needs have to be met amongst
people then it has right so to say that
to say that rights begin at birth is a
controversial thing for people because
you know they they change the equation
to life when does life begin right lots
of lots of things have life and not
rights and and and so as far as I'm
concerned it's applicable to a separate
individual and being in a social context
right I guess this is one of the ones
where people you know everyone wants a
purity test that you see this on with
every political partner now it's like
the Republicans who on a purity test
which is why they'll talk about these
rhinos Republicans in name only and you
see the Democrats doing this fighting to
be who's the most
because that's the only way you can be a
Democrat it's just silly and then in
something like this I mean I would I
would say that at at seven months
certainly that that that fetus is life
so I get what you say you're you're
human a human being it is an individual
at that point yeah it can't exist
without someone helping it and feeding
it and everything else but at seven
months this is this is a livable but
it's still breathing through the mother
it's still eating but if but if you were
to take it out at that moment yeah seven
months most likely this this can live
these are arguably I mean these are
these are the so these are the brain
areas that are very very interesting
yeah I don't think that one should ban
the the procedure at that late stage
even though I think nature sort of
compels you not to have an abortion
procedure that stage of things it makes
it extremely difficult and risky for the
mother so Nature has the final sort of
word on that but I think bands are very
risky and at the same time I think that
forcing people who find abortion morally
abhorrent to subsidize abortion or birth
control or or any other process that
they find a morally repugnant is morally
repugnant itself so I mean I think
pulling federal funding from places like
that is the beginning believe it or not
I hate to align myself folks that I
disagree with on so many other levels
but I think it's the beginning of a a
stance on the protection of individual
rights right so that's funny so in this
case you're aligning yourself with
people that you probably have no
agreement with in so many cases like
basically the Christian conservatives
right but that shows you how muddled our
politics are right that we don't really
have clean lines anymore
as to what anyone thinks so you can be
just because you're against government
control of all this suddenly you're
aligning yourself with the people that
wanna control abortion it's really it's
well I think in our politics today it's
the authoritarian you like is not an
authoritarian you know they still think
that the authoritarian ISM is good in
some respects and so unfortunately you
are gonna fall on
on weird sides of the issues that are as
they're currently you know presented
yeah so let's just knock down a couple
other controversial topics then um so
drug war I'm gonna assume you are
completely against a drug war are you
are you absolutely for legalization of
everything completely legalize it unless
you see what happens yeah is that yeah
that's it
yeah I mean I think I think there was a
time when when these kinds of drugs that
were probably thinking about as as he
lists it were legal and were you could
buy them over-the-counter and there
wasn't an epidemic that I know of you
know of opiate abuse and cocaine
addiction and heroin so it was a
systemic problem yeah and even beyond
that you you didn't create powerful
cartels that have yeah you know that can
actually determine the way countries are
governed yeah
and that were that were pretty much
animated by an ethics of violence you
know and and you didn't subject people
who wanted to procure these things to
violence which they are now and and
because that's when you make something
you make a value that people want and
have the ability to purchase a
black-market item you're just subjecting
them to an element that is far more
dangerous and those people in this law
enforcement part of the of the world
that you know goes after drug folks at
they they could be used in far more
efficient ways to keep us safe then
putting people in jail and ruining their
lives for for just purchasing something
that's outlawed right and often they're
addicts which is basically a disease I
think it's classified as a disease so
you're punishing them I mean you're and
then you're wasting state resources I
mean it's it's coupled with with a lot
of stuff so when would it be right to
use state power is there any in so if we
were attacked let's just say Canada
starts lobbing missiles from Toronto
into Detroit yeah it would be
appropriate to retaliate it would be
appropriate and so we retaliate to the
extent that you end the
Rhett permanently not contain it not
marginalize it and keep it somehow
thriving but eliminate it permanently
because the the goal of retaliatory
forces to protect the innocent so is
this the irony when that when I hear all
my progressive friends that want us out
of these wars and yet they're also for
higher taxes and yet it's our tax money
that's [ __ ] all this stuff wouldn't
you it always seems so obvious to me you
would want to starve the government of
the money so that every time they want
to build a new drone to send to
Afghanistan well maybe there's always
money for water I suppose but you would
want less government money so that they
couldn't do all these crazy adventures
right well I think the overwhelming
majority of the money that people are
the taxes are going to is the
maintenance in the welfare state the
regulatory state and a fraction of it
goes to to these to our war machine it's
hard to tell where it goes right though
like you're all that and they show us
charts and I'm always like but there's
always money for war you know it just is
always there and that's unfortunate
because yeah I think that you know there
is a there is and of course it was a
huge debate of course in the founding of
our country whether or not a standing
army was an appropriate thing for it for
a free country to have in its wings but
I do think it's an appropriate thing
given our sort of global
interconnectedness but not to create
Wars of democratization and to attempt
to change cultures but simply to protect
American lives and property and
businesses here and overseas that's it
yeah so if you became president tomorrow
knowing that we have these crazy
situations I mean Iraq actually right
now is pretty much worse than it's been
at any point in the last 20 years we're
still at war in Afghanistan I just read
that as of two weeks ago Obama's the
longest president in war ever you know
so if you or whoever the American
capitalists presidential nominee would
be how do you just end that stuff just
like I mean you literally just the day
you're in office you just rip up a lot
of treaties and you just get the hell
out of there
is that is that doable is that logical
does that create a whole other series of
problems
not to sound like a pragmatist but you
know one would have to actually get in
there you know roll up their sleeves and
see what the extent of the damage is
nothing but certainly having a a
principled foreign policy would be a
start I don't think Americans had a
principled foreign policy for decades
that kids in Beckett it's certainly not
in my lifetime I've been here 51 years
on this rock so I mean having a
principled foreign policy means
understanding that the the purpose of
government is to protect individuals and
from criminals and from firm force and
to pursue America's interests period it
would be a principle I think America has
indulged itself and sacrificial wars of
democratization and and literally their
their platform has been and I know some
folks who fought in the wars has been
literally to sacrifice American lives
for the sake of you know these other
people and cultures and and that
saccharine oils don't worry about the
oil well I don't know that we gained it
I mean that's even makes it more
appropriate to the altruist ethics I
mean I think the people that said you
know we we went in there for oil as far
as I'm concerned that would have been
somewhat a healthy a healthy motivation
in that you know a tyrant was gonna try
to take over you know in the oil and the
industrial world depends upon that it
the environmentalist have made it rather
impossible for us to kind of sustain our
own energy here through fossil fuel use
and it's it sort of made sense to keep
the oil flowing and and the wheels of
Industry turning to a degree I mean I'm
really yeah I don't and I'm not saying
that I'm that made you sound for war and
again I mean I'm saying I'm saying that
that would have been a somewhat
legitimate take on things unfortunately
it wasn't it was about making a
philosophical argument which I always
try to explain to people
different than making right rightfully
right it was about nation building we
don't need to nation build anybody we
need to just protect American citizens
so so and that that means always
reacting never initiating force against
anyone is it funny just to wrap up that
even as you were saying that that your
subconscious or whatever is back there
is going don't say something that
somebody could construe the other way
which then goes all the way around to
where we started which is this this
beast of political correctness and we've
we've got to crush it the hour is gone
which I can't believe yeah that was
crazy we we have done an hour so this
has been a pleasure and we will we will
do this again yeah and I hope some of
these ideas I think they're trick I
don't know they trickling up or
trickling down which would be the better
way and I need to do both they just all
sorts of trickling everywhere alright so
I want to thank mark Pellegrino for
joining me you guys can check out the
American capitalist society at American
capitalist society